while I was reading in the garden the
thing my great-aunt would never have
understood my doing save on a Sunday
that being the day on which it was
forbidden to indulge in any serious
occupation and on which she herself
would lay aside her sewing on a weekday
she would have said how can you go on
amusing yourself with a book it didn't
Sunday you know putting into the word
amusing an implication of childishness
and waste of time well I was reading in
the garden my hat leoni Witter would be
gossiping with françoise's until it was
time for a lily to arrive she would tell
her that she had just seen Madame who
Pete go by without an umbrella in the
silk dress she had made for her at
Chateau done if she has far to go before
Vespers she may get it properly soap
maybe maybe which also meant maybe not
was the answer for françoise's did not
wish definitely to exclude the
possibility of a happier alternative
there now said my aunt beating her brow
that reminds me I never heard if she got
to church this morning before the
elevations I must remember to ask Lily
house was just look at that black cloud
behind the sepal and how poor the
sunlight is on the slates you may be
certain it will rain before the day is
out it couldn't possibly keep on like
this it's been too hot and the sooner
the better for until the storm breaks my
DC water won't go down she concluded
since in her mind the desire to
accelerate the digestion of her be she
water was of instantly greater
importance than her fear of seeing
Madame goo pedals new dress ruined
maybe maybe and you know when it that
when it rains in the square there's not
much sought shelter suddenly I am turn
pale what three o'clock shakes claimed
but debt Spurs will have begun already
and I've forgotten my pets in now I know
why that DC water has been lying on my
stomach and grabbing hold a hold of a
prayer book found in purple velvet with
gilt clasps on which in her haste she
left for all a shower of the little
pictures each and a lace fringe of
yellow paper which she used to mark the
places of the greater pieces of the
church my aunt while she swallowed her
drops began to at full speed to mutter
the words of the sacred texts its
meaning being slightly clouded in her
brain by the uncertainty whether the
pepsin when taken so long after the V
she would still be over still be able to
overtake it and thus to send it down
three o'clock it's incredible how time
flies a little tap at the window as
though something that struck it followed
by a plentiful falling sound as light as
if a shower of sand were being dropped
from a window overhead then the fall
spreading taking on order a rhythm
becoming liquid loud musical innumerable
Universal it was the rain there France
was what did I tell you how it's coming
down but I think I heard the bell at the
garden gate go along and see who could
be outside in this weather françoise's
went and returned its madam on ad my
grandmother
she said she was going for a walk it's
raining hard all the same I'm not at all
surprised sit my ass looking up to the
sky I've always said that she was not in
the least like other people well I'm
glad it's she and not myself who's
outside in this rain meta momma Dee is
always the exact opposite of them the
rest said françoise's not unkindly
reflect reframing until she was alone
with the other servants from stating her
belief that my grandmother was a bit off
her head the benediction is over later
he will never come outside my app it
will be the weather that's frightened
her away but it's not five o'clock yet
maghanap time it's only half past four
only half past four and Here I am
obliged to draw back the small Curtis
just to get a miserable streak of a like
a half past four only a week before the
rotation days I had poor Francois the
good Lord must be sorely vexed with us
the world is going too far these days as
my poor octave used to say we have
forgotten the good Lord too often and he
is taking vengeance on us a bright flash
animated my aunt's cheeks it was a
living as luck would have it scarcely
had she been admitted when Francois has
reappeared and with a smile that was
meant to indicate her full participation
in the pleasure which she had no doubt
her tidings would give my aunt
articulating each syllable so as to show
that in spite of her having to translate
them into indirect speech she was
repeating as a good servant shows the
very words that the new visitor had
condescended to use said his reverence
the QA would be delighted and chant
if Madame Appa is not resting just now
and could see me his reference does not
wish to disturb Madame atop his
references downstairs I told him to go
into the parallel had the truth be known
the curious visit did not please might
have nearly as much as Francois supposed
and the air of jubilation with which she
felt bound to illuminate her face
whenever she had to announce his arrival
did not altogether correspond to what
was felt by her invalid the QA an
excellent man with whom I am sorry now i
did not converse more often for even if
he cared nothing for the arts he knew a
great many etymologies the q la being in
the habit of giving distinguished
visitors information about the church
had even planned to compile a history of
the parish of complain used to weary her
with his endless explanations which
incidentally never varied in the least
degree but when his visit coincided
exactly with her leaves his presence
became frankly distasteful to aunt she
would have preferred to make the most of
her friend and not to have everyone at
the same time but she dared not send a
cure a away and had to content herself
with making assigned to Elodie not to
leave when he did so that she might have
her to herself for a little after he had
gone what is this hyphen hearing father
that an artist has set up his easel in
your church and is copying one of the
windows old as I am I can safely say
that I have never even heard of such a
thing in all my life what is this world
coming to next I wonder and the ugliest
thing in the whole church too I will not
go so far as to say
that is quite the ugliest for although
there are certain things in santee
layout that are well worth a visit there
are others that are very old now in my
poor Basilica the only one in all the
diocese that has never even been
restored God knows our porch is dirty
and out-of-date still it is of a
majestic character the same can be said
of the ester tapestries though
personally I would not give two sous for
them but experts put them next after the
ones at songs I can quite see to that
apart from certain details that are
trifle realistic then show others that
testify to a genuine power or
observation but don't talk to me about
the windows is it common sense to leave
up windows that shut out all the
daylight and even confuse the eyes by
throwing patches of color that I
wouldn't even know how to describe on a
floor in which there are not two slabs
on the same level and yet they refused
to renew the floor for me on the pretext
that those slabs are the tombstones of
the abbot's of comply and the Lords of
care among the old comes upper bunk
direct ancestors of the present to
particular moment and of his Duchess
also since she was a madam was out to
get home who married who married her
cousin my grandmother by dint of
refusing to take any interest in persons
had added in confusing all their names
and titles and whenever anyone mentioned
to do Chester go home she used to make
out that she must be related to Madame
Devine path see the whole family would
then burst out laughing and she would
attempt to justify herself by harking
back to some gear mom to some invitation
to a christening
or a funeral I feel sure there was a
camel in there somewhere and for once I
would side with the others and against
her refusing to admit that there could
be any connection between her boarding
school friend and the descendant of Jean
via de Brabant look at Bouchon key to
cure a baton it is nothing more nowadays
than a parish of farmers though in olden
times that locality must have had a
considerable importance from its trade
and felt act and clocks I am NOT certain
of the etymology of her song being I
would dearly like to think that the name
was originally movie from rod goofy wila
analogous to Chateau castrum rabble feet
but we will talk about that some other
time very well the church there has
superb windows almost all quite modern
including that most important imposing
entry of Louis Philippe into coli which
would be more in keeping surely at
cambrai itself and which is every bit as
good I understand as the famous windows
at sharp only yesterday I met dr. pecks
pas brother who knows all about these
things and he told me that he looked on
it as a most beautiful piece of work but
as I said to this artist who by the way
seems to be a most civil fellow and is
as it appears a true virtuoso with his
brush what on earth do you find so
extraordinary in this window which is if
anything a little darker than the rest